everybody dick's different you got small
[ __ ] big [ __ ] ben [ __ ] if she's read
through like
if she got mileage
can't do it anything that comes by i'm
going to take
i don't think that's true at all
terrible
does a woman's body count matter when
picking a partner like how many people
they've slept with before oh yeah hell
yeah oh yeah yeah you don't want a girl
with a high body count you want to like
explain your your reasoning for that
when the more body cones you have
it's just going to be all type of
nixon all type of [ __ ] she got all this
[ __ ] in the world what she got already
yeah i mean we can't please her no more
you know every dick's different let's
put it as that everybody looks different
you got small [ __ ] big [ __ ] ben [ __ ] all
type of [ __ ] so she's been through all
them [ __ ] she's done now
okay no i think there could be a point
where i would care i mean if they can't
count them maybe i think that people
like can change and grow up especially
if you if you start having sex when
you're 16 or whatever
and you're not mature yet like you don't
really mature until you're like i don't
know for guys like who knows ever but i
think like that stuff can get pretty
high if you're going out every weekend
and having sex like it doesn't like
wouldn't that be like wouldn't you see
that as a problem if they're going out
every weekend and then just like having
sex with someone new i think it depends
on
if they've like
transformed like i'm not gonna get not
give someone the benefit of the doubt no
no not at all no okay do you think it's
different for when guys are picking
girls um should should they care about
body count or you don't think that
matters either no i don't i don't think
anyone should care okay so like if
someone sleeps with a bunch of people it
has no no judgment on it doesn't affect
your judgment at all on if you should
like uh start dating them no judgment
yeah
um
like in theory no i don't know it might
leave like a bad taste in my mouth no i
don't think i would even really like
bring that up at the beginning of a
relationship okay what do you think
yeah as long as they're clean yeah okay
do you think it's the same for guys to
girls so when a guy is judging on if he
should date a girl or not like it's it
shouldn't matter no i think guys care
more so
i think the same but i don't want to
explain why
do you think like it's because men want
like loyalty in a woman that's like a
big factor when picking a girlfriend i
think everyone wants loyalty and a
partner yeah but that's definitely part
of it i think men are more harsh on
women um you think men are more harsh
when picking women yeah
yeah and judging them i would disagree
i'd say women are more harsh on picking
men because it's a lot easier for women
to pull a lot of men than for men to
pull a lot of women you know
i don't think that's true at all really
i disagree so i like if you i don't know
i'd say like if a woman slept with 20
men and a man slept with 20 men it's
like a totally different thing because
for a man to sleep with 20 people he has
to like have redeeming features and
really like work at himself to even be
able to sleep with a lot of people while
a woman could be like this sounds bad
like at the lower of like the spectrum
and she could still sleep with 20 people
you know terrible do you know what i'm
saying though i think they should be are
equal i'm with emma here no not at all
no no yeah so are they no okay shouldn't
even be discussed it doesn't need to be
no i don't think so fro you know i don't
think so okay
we all guys right we know our body
council like why would you care what
what their body count is so yeah i guess
i hear what you're saying
me personally
if she's read through like
if she got mileage
can't do it it's a high mileage car it's
more likely to break down
oh
i like experience but not too much if
you know at the end of the day we're not
all gonna be virgins exactly
not really but i mean if it's crazy
astronomical that's worrying but
i mean
it depends how old you are and how long
you've been in the game but i guess if
you're
in your like 20s and you got like
i don't know like upwards of like 30 40
50 like when you start getting up there
you start to ask some questions do you
know what body count is like how many
people a woman has slept with
so does that affect your decision when
um if you're deciding if you want to
date a girl or not no no no
really so it doesn't matter to you at
all no
okay anything that goes by i'm gonna
take
does body count matter when picking a
partner
like how many people they've slept with
yeah um
[Music]
i feel like there is like a number
that's high that you might want to be
concerned about but
i don't think it needs to like totally
dictate yeah like it's not like the
biggest fact but it's definitely
would you say it's different for boys or
girl like boys and girls so like would
you say it's like a different metric for
for the genders no i don't think so i
feel like it should be do you think it
matters the same yeah i agree no not at
all not at all so even if they slept
with like 25 people you think it'll have
like no effect on how the relationship
goes no because mine might be up there
too might as well yeah that's what would
be the same so do you don't think it's
any different for a woman to have a high
body count compared to a man having a
high body count
it would have to be pretty egregious but
for the most part it's not going to do
i'm not going to do it from we'll change
it as long as i'm into it okay that's
fair uh would you say it's easier for a
woman to attain a high body count than
for a man to have a high body count
obtain yeah so like if a woman has 20
bodies is it the same as a guy having 20
bodies i would say most people are gonna
say no for sure but i i
again going back to the previous
question i don't think it's gonna matter
too much to me but i would say less
people are gonna know that she has 20. i
feel like it's hidden a little bit
better than the man at the end of the
day it's not like you're ever going to
know the real number yeah perfect thank
you guys so much for watching you know
it's always important to get other
people's takes some controversial topics
really gets your brain thinking i'm
giving a hundred dollars to someone who
likes and drops a sub and then dms me
proof on instagram let's make this [ __ ]
huge guys
[Music]
god
[Music]